[Musique]
2 x 2 cela fait cela fait pas grand
chose je continue tant pis 2 x 3 2 x 3
ça fait déjà ça fait un peu plus ouais
ouais
deux fois 4 alors ça deux fois 4 onces à
sable en fer entre les six et encore les
bon je vais vérifier avec ma règle à
calcul oui ma règle à calcul pour ça
fait rien je je je pose lui car je
retiens 12 cela me donne
cela me donne l'âge du capitaine
or alors qu'est ce que çà et là ça m'a
l'air très sérieuse que tu fais là tu as
des devoirs à faire pour demain matin
non pas du tout je prépare mes coups
mois pour enseigner à l'école de l'île
aux enfants comme peut le voir sur ce
tableau
j'aurais enseigner le calcul la
géométrie et la pifométrie la lapi faux
mais coin la pifométrie qu'est ce que
c'est je viens je suis pas très forte en
mathématiques mais jamais on peut
réparer delà de la pifométrie non c'est
normal c'est une science tout à fait
nouvelle dont je suis le génial
inventeur
bon je t'expliquerai ça plus tard pas
t'asseoir tu seras ma première élève
alors je pose huit genres à majorque ya
12 juin je tiens sortient l'âge du
capitaine
qui a dit ça c'est moi qui me retient
bien puisque cinq soeurs et les propos
que vous arriviez en retard est déjà
assez grave
que vous soyez sans mon excuse n'étant
plus ça pour semer la perturbation ça
devient intolérable
julie qu'est ce qui arriva casimir il a
l'air de très mauvaise humeur en soit je
ne supporte pas que l'on touche à
pendant les cours
alors qu'on évoque en trio un cahier et
allez vous asseoir
oui monsieur si on recommence
may cry va passer les virages et je
trace en rond on ne dit pas rond mais un
cercle qui a dit ça c'est moi monsieur
on ne dit pas un héros mais un cercle et
là françois fortin journée c'est moi
c'est toujours pareil on ne dit pas un
mot ni un cercle et puis d'abord c'est
un carré sortais je vous avait pourtant
prévenu comment s'appelle cette figure
géométrique et bien je crois aucun nul
il me semble que c'est un carré je crois
pour total 1 très bien j'aime ça vous
aurez 0 ah ça c'est haro par exemple
enfin je veux dire à serques julie
sortait au bac où tu veux bien casimir
mais tu n'auras plus d'élèves et et tu
ne pourras pas savoir si taux courts est
au point non mais c'est vrai je n'ai pas
pensé il tombe alors si toi elle et ne
t'inquiète pas nous appelons françois et
les enfants ils vont aider françois les
enfants venez voir fierté venez les
enfants nous allons essayer d'aider
casimir a trouvé le nom de certaines
formes géométriques très bonne idée
regarde casimir voilà
qu'est-ce que je les reconnais moi c'est
une boule dont casimir très bien c'est
une sphère mort quand je joue à la
pétanque se joue en sport si tu veux
qu'elles s'ignorent tu as peu près
compris
enfin de toute façon la géométrie un à
côté de la pifométrie c'est vraiment
très facile très facile là puis soul et
ricky sexuelle oui c'est d'après casimir
une science très nouvelles dont il est
le génial inventeur royal on est bien
casimir vu tes connaissances en
géométrie d'une permettra d'être un
petit peu méfiants quant à cette science
que tu réinventer mon pauvre françois tu
fais partie de ces gens qui pensent que
la terre est encore plein alors que tout
le monde sait qu'à les bullet sérique
enfin la terre est bien composée de deux
emmy seront deux hémisphères kymera l'on
ne vous chamailler pas sans soins laisse
casimir expliquer sa fameuse pifométrie
pas joli comment veux tu que je
travaille dans une crypte atmos boules
de m
tu veut sans doute dire une atmosphère
défiance françois sois gentil casimir
nous écoutons aller alors la pifométrie
il est une science qui permet de deviner
des figures et des volumes géométriques
les yeux fermés parfaitement je vais
vous faire une démonstration
cash et moi les yeux avec quoi ça vient
magazine et là tu ne vas pas je ne vois
rien parfait maintenant prenez ce
plateau alors je commence la
démonstration
bien ceci est un cylindre de chez bras
ceci est en rectangle de peau l'yvette
le rythme de pont l'évêque ne pas
confondre avec le carré de l'extension
ceci est un cercle de camembert ça c'est
une magnifique boules de relance et pour
terminer un triangle de bris voilà
quelques-unes il
[Musique]